well this is big for the first time
since march fans are being allowed to
actually go
to a sporting event right here in
southern nevada
ron futrell joining us now as the las
vegas motor speedway is breaking some
ground this weekend ron
they are indeed denise state officials
would not allow fans at the nascar race
in september you'll recall
that caused a bit of anxiety and some
anger here in the valley
but that's changing this weekend the
nhra is in town beginning today running
through sunday
they hold the drags out at the speedway
twice a year at the strip there
the spring race was canceled but the
race this weekend
is a go and it's a big one the dodge
nhra finals
fans are already going through the
screening process you got temperature
checks
bag checks they have ticketless entry
you got to wear a mask
and all the precautions to start getting
fans back at sporting events in southern
nevada are taking place
uh we're really excited about the fact
that we're going to become the first
sports event
in the state of nevada since the
pandemic broke out to be able to host
fans
it's been a long time since people have
been able to come out and we think that
we can start small
and build on that and there's no better
person to do
it right the las vegas motor speedway
it's nice to get out
and be able to go you know to the drag
races and
you know some some i say sense of
normalcy
oh that will be a good feel so fans are
already at the track of speedway right
now
10 percent capacity is what they're
limited to that means about three
thousand fans each day as you can
imagine they're already sold
out they expect those fans to have a
good time enjoy themselves out there in
social distance at all times
but with this happening and fans being
allowed at the rebel football game on
saturday night at the legion stadium
what do you know we're starting to get
back to normal just a bit
kirsten we will take it safely bit by
bit all right thanks very much for that
good news ron